all right welcome back everybody before
we get started today I doesn't really
have any questions about logistics or
midterm or anything like that we'll be
doing a midterm review on Monday at the
midterm will be on Wednesday because
there's a number of people in the class
we're gonna be spreading everybody
across a couple of rooms and we'll be
sending instructions out about that they
may have any other logistics questions
instructions will also be on the web but
you're allowed to bring a one page of
written notes aside from that everything
is a closed book yeah whereas behavior
may be already issued a pulse no matter
just double-checking disease okay all
right okay let's go ahead and get
started
um before we do that I just want to say
thank you to all of you that
participated in the class feedback
survey it's really helpful to me and to
everybody else to understand what's
helping you learn and what's not helping
you learn oh okay so in terms of the
responses so note you know all of these
things there's about two hundred and
thirty people registered in the class so
for some of you if you didn't give me
feedback it's hard for me to know what
what's helping you or not helping you
learn so we're just gonna go with what
people gave us feedback on about sixty
five percent of you thought it's the
right pace about twenty seven percent of
you thought it's going too fast and
there's only about eight percent of
people that think it's going too slowly
so we're gonna keep roughly in the same
pace as what we've had before a number
of people noted that they wish it was
like a semester long course I will
mention there's a number of other
classes that do reinforcement learning
them and I highly encourage you to take
them I offer an advanced class and also
been Van Roy offers a class normally in
the spring that's more theoretical this
was super controversial I didn't think
it would be this split so we offer
sessions on Thursday and Friday
attendance has been really low I think
we've had around like three to seven
people showing up for the sessions so we
thought this was going to be something
that everybody wanted to take out
because it's about evenly split
I asked all the C
to compare the people that are coming to
their office hours versus the people
that are coming to sessions we probably
have about 4 to 5 X people trying to go
to office hours and trying to go to
sessions so we're gonna switch this to
office hours just so that we can kind of
serve as many people as we can so just
write that there so we're gonna switch
to office hours now the sessions will
still be offered on the other days and
they'll still be recorded so for anybody
who wanted to go to them on Thursday and
Friday you can still go you can still
participate on zoom' or you can watch
the recorded lecture but we're gonna
switch this to office hours because my
CAS have been saying they've had a
number of office hours where they've
either had to stay really later they
feel like they're not getting to some
people and so again just in terms of
serving than most people I will say when
I was going through these responses it
really made me think about the fact that
in reinforcement learning and sort of
sequential decision-making in general
we're always optimizing for expected
rewards and so that's kind of exactly
the same thing we're doing here is that
I know that everybody needs slightly
different things and we're just trying
to do our best job and expectation but
it's exactly why things like intelligent
tutoring systems and other stuff might
be better ok in terms of things that
people thought were working well for
them we've got a number of positive
remarks about doing worked examples in
class doing derivations a lot of people
really like the fact that my iPad had
problems on Monday and so that we did
things on the board so we'll try to keep
doing the same amount or more of
derivation so people also were generally
really positive about the homeworks in
terms of things we saw repeatedly so so
what I did is I got I just collated sort
of all the free responses and tried to
look for common themes and anything that
came up you know 3 or 5 times or more I
considered it was a common issue that
people would love addressed people would
love even more focus on the big picture
explaining as well as connecting from
the toy examples to real-world examples
so we'll try to do that where we can
I'll also try to make sure that I'm
speaking loudly throughout several
people said that sometimes it was
occasionally hard to hear so I'll try to
do a better job on that if you can't
hear me in the back please feel free to
raise your hand
and people would like even more examples
of worked examples and so in particular
we're gonna try to make sure that in
sessions we emphasize worked examples
even more and let me just say again if
this was not one of the things that you
were most concerned about I'm sorry we
can't address all of them this term we
definitely and it was kind of amusing to
go through this would have people saying
exactly opposite things sometimes right
in a row them in terms of how it was
collated about things like some people
don't like the fact that the slides have
gaps and I do derivations in class and a
number of other people really like that
I do a retardation in class some people
felt like it was moving too slowly other
people said it was moving way too fast
so again we're just gonna try to do the
best job we can to address everybody's
needs alright so today we're going to
continue talking about policy search
which as I said before is probably the
most important reinforcement learning
thing you'll learn this term I think
this is used really very widely right
now in order to optimize functions and
we can again think of policy search here
is a lot of things are gonna sound
similar to when we were doing value
function approximation and what we're
thinking about here is having a
parameterised policy often we're gonna
use theta to parameterize it but we
could use w or anything else but we have
a policy that's parameterised and then
we have some value of that policy and
what we're gonna want to be doing is
trying to find you know a good optima
trying to maximize the value of that
policy and one of the reasons why we did
this right after imitation learning was
to connect it with the idea of you have
to choose a policy class a way to
specify that parameterization and so
because of that inherently it's a place
to put in structure ok so just as a
recap I mentioned that we've done a lot
of work so far on model free value based
methods we're starting to do work on
direct policy search methods now and
today we'll also start to talk more
about actor critic methods where we
maintain both we maintain both an
explicit parametrize policy and an
explicit parametrize value function and
also throughout all of you know the last
couple weeks and
hooting yesterday or Monday and today
we're mostly going to be talking about
cases where we want to be able to work
in really really large state spaces so
I'm just gonna do a brief refresher of
last time why do we want to do this well
we're gonna generally be able to
guarantee that we converge to a local
optima we don't always have those
guarantees for value function based
methods and that might be important well
it's a nice property to have the
downside is that if you use policy
gradient methods typically we only
converge to a local optima the last time
I showed you the exoskeleton an example
where they're using a global Optima
approach so there are other ones which
can policy based RL isn't inherently
always gonna get you to a local solution
but the gradient based methods typically
will and the other issue that we were
talking about as ways to try to address
this is or tools to address the fact
that evaluating a policy itself might be
rather inefficient and high variance so
what we were defining before is a policy
gradient where now I before we sort of
thought about these things being
parameterize by a theta so we can either
think of the value being the policy
being parametrized by theta or pi of
theta being advertised but we're also
going to talk about value functions
because ultimately the value function
depends on the policy and the policy
depends on the parameters and when we
think about what we want out of these
algorithms typically what we'd really
like is to try to converge to a really
good local optima often we don't have
very much control over that but the
things we often do have control over is
things like how quickly we converge to
that local optima and so we want to use
sort of go as quickly as we can down
that gradient if we're doing a gradient
based method and use our data as well as
we can so one of the things we're going
to talk more about today is when we're
doing this sort of policy gradient
technique so we're gonna be sort of
moving down now we're gonna have our
gradient have our function so this is B
pi this is our parameter I
and as we're moving down towards some
local gradient it would be nice if when
we update our policy that it is
monotonically improving so can anybody
give me a reason why we might want
monotonic improvement yeah
thank you conversions the answer is but
I can help guarantee convergence
absolutely and while I love math as much
as many of you that that is a great
reason but perhaps I was also thinking
of like an empirical reason why we might
want that as well yeah in the back
as you're gonna deploy these like in a
high-stakes situation so what we've seen
before in fact one of my students
give me the practice job talk yesterday
and he was showing this graph for dqn
which looks something like this where
this is like the performance this is the
reward and this is time
it's look like this and typically when
you go to when you read papers people
smooth over many many runs but often it
looks something like that
that as you're going across multiple
episodes or across multiple time steps
like you're really getting a very jagged
up and down performance of your of your
about of the policy that you're running
as you do DQ n so why might that not be
good in like a high-stakes situation
yeah over there
it's name versus if like it's something
I stakes and you have something good and
then it goes down people are gonna be
upset with you that you've now done
something worse even if they later go
back out yo
if you do you know if your policy works
pretty well and then the next one next
episode it works really badly even if it
might go up later you know your boss
still might fire you
I mean I'm joking but I think that
people are often loss averse and also
it's often not tolerable in it might not
be okay you know in a company to say
well this quarter we did really well and
next quarter we're gonna do you know
worse but then eventually you know after
many quarters we're gonna do well like
we often may want to ensure that we're
sort of monotonically going up and in
the case of something like patient
treatment or other sort of high-stakes
scenarios or airplanes or stuff like
that it just probably will not be
tolerable to people if you say we're
gonna do much worse for this period of
time now there exceptions to all of this
but I think there are many cases where
you'd really like monotonic improvement
if you can so I think it's a really in
addition to the theoretical benefits it
can help us prove things it also can
just be something that sort of appealing
for people to actually be able to deploy
and we know that in general that people
are very risk like very loss averse so
having policies that are monotonically
improving can be very nice and dqn and a
lot of the value based methods do not
have those guarantees we can talk more
also about whether that's always
possible in terms of if you wanted to
get to a global Optima yes on data that
you have access to or have seen right so
technically like if there's a
distribution in terms of your live
environment where it may differ somewhat
from your actual simulation or
you may not want to kind of improve it
even in austerity is that right which is
to say when we're gonna be what's you
know what is this monotonic improvement
what are the conditions under which this
will be guaranteed or possible and are
we sort of doing this based on our
previous data and making some assumption
about the future data that's collected
absolutely we're going to assume that
we're still in the same decision process
and that it's stationary and what I mean
by that is that the transition model and
the reward model is the same across you
know you might not have observed all the
states yet but it's the same across
episodes so we're not dealing with the
fact that you know customer preferences
have totally changed or you know climate
change is changing your environment we
are dealing with the fact that if the
world is stationary that then we're
gonna be guaranteed to have monotonic
improvement now the other thing that or
I'm going to show you that in some cases
we can guarantee that the other really
important thing to know is this is gonna
we're gonna hope to show monotonic
improvement in expectation so so the
value function is expected reward so
what we're going to be able to hope to
say is the series of policies that were
deployed in the environment that their
value function is going up so what does
that mean that's it means that V pi-1 we
would like that to be less than or equal
to V PI to less than equal to B pi/3 dot
where they say is sort of the policy we
deploy on each iteration reach-around
all right but it doesn't guarantee that
for a single run this policy is better
so you could easily have it that on
average you're deploying a policy that
is better you know for your airplanes or
for patient treatment etc but they're
for individual patients that might be
worse and I think a really interesting
active area of research right now is
safe reinforcement learning and safe
exploration and a lot of different
people are thinking about this including
a number of people here at Stanford and
one of the things that we're looking at
in our group is how do you really
efficiently get to a safe solution what
drug you mean by safe in this case I
mean you might not want to match
maximized expected reward you might want
to be able to maximize
some sort of risk-averse criteria and
we'd like to figure out ways to really
efficiently get to that solution but
there's lots of really interesting stuff
that says you know how do we try to do
policy search or how do we do this an
improvement in cases where we don't just
care about expected outcomes all right
so we're going to be trying to do today
is move towards sort of ideally not just
monotonic improvements but large
monotonic improvements as you might
guess it is easier to try to achieve
small monotonic improvements than it
would be to guarantee really large
monotonic improvements
does anybody have any intuition for why
that would be true
I'm gonna be harder this kind of goes
back to the state distributions so if
you change your policy a lot does the
state can the state distribution change
a lot in terms of the states you visit
so intuitively that should the answer
should be yes so we've talked some about
how any policy induces a state
distribution like if you run it for a
long time you're gonna have sort of a
stationary distribution over states and
if your policy is really different than
your old policy then that state
distribution might look really different
which means you might not have very much
data whereas if you have almost exactly
the same policy as before you're
probably gonna be able to have a really
good notion of what that value is in the
estimate but we'll get more into that
later so what we're gonna do today is to
try to think about moving beyond what we
were talking about last time where we're
trying to do policy gradient methods and
we're trying to do it in a way that was
sort of efficient we're gonna talk about
other ways to make it more efficient and
less noisy and then try to go towards
monotonic improvement all right so the
things that we talked about last time is
we started off and we said what could we
do in terms of policy gradient one thing
we could do is kind of you do Monte
Carlo returns so these are Monte Carlo
returns and sometimes people use big R
of tau where tile this is a trajectory
so you could just run out your policy
till the world terminates or H steps or
however you're defining your episodes
and then look at the reward and look at
the reward across you know per time step
we can also use G I T to denote the
reward we get from time step T and in
episode I and what we've said before is
that this is an unbiased estimate of the
gradient but it's really noisy and so we
started talking about additional
structure we could use in the
reinforcement learning problem where
we're assuming the world is Markov to
try to reduce the variance of this
estimate and so what we talked about
last time was using temporal structure
which we did someone on the board and
the intuition there was
reward you get at some time point can be
is not influenced by the later decisions
you make so you didn't have to take kind
of this complete product of the
probability of action given the states
because future actions don't retro
actively change your earlier rewards for
intuition so we're gonna start talking
about now is um other things which is
baselines and alternatives to Monte
Carlo so what's the baseline well a
baseline is let's still think about
looking at the sum of rewards we get
from this time step onwards so this is
the same thing that we've often called
GT so this is the reward we get from
this time step to the end of the episode
and we are gonna subtract a baseline
that depends on the state and what I'm
going to show shortly is that by
subtracting this baseline which depends
only on the state your resulting
gradient estimator can still be unbiased
but it might not have much lower
variance and in particular often a
really good choice is the expected
return which is basically the value
function and so why would we do this
well then we can kind of look at we're
increasing the log probability of an
action proportional to how much better
it is than a baseline which in general
is can end up being sort of a little bit
like an advantage function so why is
this true okay so what are we going to
try to do here we're gonna say we have
this high variance estimate right now if
we don't have imagine we didn't have
this we don't have that we have our the
standard estimate we were talking about
last type and what I want to convince
you is that if we subtract off this
thing which is a function of the state
that an expectation that additional term
we're subtracting off is zero meaning
that our estimator is still unbiased so
I said our original estimator is
unbiased
now we're subtracting off this weird
thing we want to show that the resulting
estimator is still unbiased and the way
we do that is by showing the goal is to
show that this is equal to zero
so that's what we're gonna try and do
and if we can show that then that's
gonna justify why we can subtract this
random thing and then we can start to
talk about what that random thing should
be but first we're just gonna show no
matter what that random thing is if it's
a function only of the state that this
expectation is zero so how do we do this
well first of all notice on the outside
there's an expectation over tau that is
all the trajectories we might encounter
by running our current policy so what
I'm gonna do first is I'm just gonna
split it into two parts so this is still
tau and all I've done here is I've split
it into the first part which is all the
way up to time step T and the second
part which is on time step T all the way
to the end so I've just sort of
decomposed that I've just written out
what a trajectory is and then decompose
it into two parts so I'm just
decomposing the trajectory and once we
do that then we can see that the
baseline term is only a function of s T
so we can pull it out of this in inner
term so we're gonna pull this out
because it doesn't depend on any of
these future time stamps it's
independent of those
then the next thing what we're gonna do
is we're going to write out or note the
fact that in this case that all we have
in this inner term here is st and 80 so
we can drop all the future terms again
this or the the prone lis thing in here
is the probability of the action at time
step T given the state T and theta so we
don't need to worry about the future
states or the future actions that are
taken where were independent of those so
now so we just pulled out the first we
pulled out baseline and now we're gonna
drop those things that we don't need to
depend on so all we have here is an
expectation over the action that's taken
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to read so what is this
expectation it's an expectation over 80
what is the problem you know what is
that expectation we're just gonna write
that out explicitly that depends on the
policy that we have so we're gonna sum
over 80 the probability of that 80 which
of course just depends on the policy
that we're following times the
derivative of log so that is me writing
out the expectation and now I'm going to
take the derivative of the log
so that's just gonna be the derivative
with respect to the policy itself
divided by PI of 80s T theta but now we
note that there's a terma on the
numerator in term of the denominator
that we can cancel so this starts to
simplify it be a vest T times the sum
over 80 just the derivative of the
policy just cancelled numerator and
denominator there and now we note that
we can reverse the sum and the
derivative this is the other side kind
of critical step of this proof so now
what we're going to do here is we're
going to move the derivative out well
this is just 1 because the probability
that we select some action under our
policy always has to be 1 and so now we
see that we're just taking the
derivative of 1 so we're trying to take
the derivative of 1 and of course that's
a constant so this is equal to 0 so it's
pretty cool so that means that we have
added in this baseline that is some
function that depends on the state we
haven't said we told me you know we
haven't talked about all the different
ways we could compute that yet or say it
doesn't matter what it is no matter what
you add in there it's always unbiased so
just to check our understanding for a
second if we go back to this equation if
I set B of s T to be a constant
everywhere is the gradient estimator
still unbiased
it's just eight plates one minute and
touch your neighbor they fight so based
on what I've just said if B of s T is
equal to a constant this is a constant
for all s T is the gradient estimator
and last stake like one second I want to
talk to you right so let's start with
everybody who thinks it's still unbiased
vote yes great okay yes it has this'll
be unbiased now it's a function not even
of s it's just a constant and so it is
definitely a function of NS it's a
trivial function where it doesn't matter
what the value of s is and so it's still
unbiased just to note here and if s
wasn't fun if the baseline was a
function of state and action do you
think this proof would go through no
right because one of the things that we
did at the very beginning is we move B
of s T all the way out and if it depends
on the action too we couldn't have done
that so this is specific to this being
only a function of the state yes use
only a function of the state all of them
run by step yeah
there's always some bias there could be
really I mean just like what I put here
you could just put in a constant and it
might not reduce your variance at all so
there's certainly unuseful definitions
of a baseline but all of them are
unbiased so they're not gonna affect
whether or not your estimator is
unbiased they could make your estimator
potentially worse if they're really bad
or they're really themselves very bad
estimators potentially and they
certainly could make it better
by choosing good choices all right so
this ends up may allowing us to define
what sort of known as the vanilla policy
gradient algorithm so vanilla policy
gradient operates by we collect a bunch
of trajectories using our current policy
and then for each time step inside of
the trajectory we compute the return
from that time step to the end and then
we compute the advantage estimate so all
right we're right out vanilla policy
gradient okay so vanilla policy gradient
works as follows you start up you
initialize the policy with some
parameter theta and you need to start
with some estimate of the baseline okay
so what happens with vanilla policy
gradient is four iterations I equals 1
to dot we're gonna collect a set of
trajectories using your current policy
and then for each time step for T equals
1 dot the length of your trajectory I
then you do two things you compute the
return which is just equal to the sum of
all the returns till the end of the
episode and then you compute the
advantage a hat i T which is just equal
to this return I'll parameterize it with
I just to show that that's the I
trajectory minus B of s T
so just to note here for a second um
this is a return of the sum of rewards
till the end of the episode this is the
baseline which is like a fixed function
so this could be you know a deep neural
network this could be a table lookup but
this is a function and you input the
state a time step T in trajectory I and
you output a scalar so that's what the
baseline is doing there and then what in
vanilla policy gradient we do is then we
refit the baseline so in this case the
baseline is going to be an estimate of
the average of the G's so in vanilla
policy base vanilla policy gradient what
we do is the next step is we sum over
all the trajectories you got so far
we've sum over all the time steps and we
do basically just a least squares fit so
note this could be done with like
student this is supervised learning we
just have some a baseline function that
could be parametrized I'll make sure to
put an eye there so we have a baseline
function that could be parameterize with
some totally other weights or parameters
and then we have our returns G that
we've seen so far we just try to
minimize that distance and so then the
baseline is really representing the
expected sum of rewards
note that this is in some ways a little
bit funny right because we're using all
of our data that we've ever seen so this
can either be done over all the data
you've ever ever seen or it can be done
over just the most recent round there's
lots of choices for how to do the
baseline okay if you use all the data
you've ever ever seen then which is what
this would do then you could be
averaging over lots of different
policies because you've got data from
different policies if you just do this
over the most recent round then you're
just gonna be getting an estimate of
essentially beep aya beep I like the
iteration this is gonna end up
approximating
if you doing it over their trajectories
if you don't do this but you sum it over
the trajectories for this round I guess
the way I've written this is a little
bit unclear so let me see if I can make
that a bit clearer so let's say that we
have a you have D trajectories so we do
it this way then that's exactly equal to
V PI I so I now is the iteration D is
the trajectories we've gathered just on
iteration I so this is only averaging
over the policies for this particular
the the trajectories for this particular
policy I say that a bit odd does anybody
have any questions about exactly what
we're doing in this case so normally in
this situation there's a number of
series of browns this is for each so
we're gonna have a series of PI's
basically and then for each policy we're
gonna have a set of trajectories and for
each trajectory we have a set of time
steps and what this is saying here is
average over all the trajectories you
have for the current policy and fit the
baseline to that alright and then once
you have that so this gives you the
baseline and then we do update the
policy using your gradient and it's
going to be a sum of terms that include
these derivatives with respect to the
policy and your advantage function so
you're gonna take in this advantage
function that you compute it over here
and then you're gonna be multiplying it
by what was the probability of the
actions given the state and theta the
log derivative of that and then we plug
that let's get this estimate of the
gradient into something like stochastic
gradient descent or Adam something else
so this is vanilla policy gradient and
what we're gonna see during the rest of
today is just a number of different
slight variants on this basic template
so I'll get to you just a second but I
just want to emphasize that if you if
you when you walk away from understood
like from what I'd like you to
understand from the main idea for Policy
gradient is essentially what's on the
board right now is that what we're doing
is we are running we take one policy we
get a bunch of data from it then we have
to fit something like an advantage
there's going to be different ways to
compute that we could end up doing
bootstrapping
to do some sort of TV estimate or we can
just directly use the returns we often
use a baseline that we're fitting over
time and then we're gonna update the
policy and have to choose some step size
with respect to the gradient so this is
sort of the most important thing has to
say hey there's this basic template for
almost all policy gradient algorithms I
can choose different things to kind of
plug in here and I can choose different
ways to take my step sizes and that's
going to define a whole bunch of the
different policy gradient algorithms
that you see should are we using to
represent biases that we think it's
creating so I'm asking you know how do
we represent the policy so we can take
its gradient we have to be able to take
this here we talked briefly about this
last time and but it was also on the
board near the end Gaussian work softmax
is both there both of those you can
analytically take the derivative and
often we use deep neural networks or
shallow deep neural networks yes I saw a
question back there and main first
please
I was wearing if there's any issue with
they like the non stationing like the
the baseline with neural medic there's
like non-stationary issues with that so
I believe is to say you asked me on the
baseline right so like how we are there
non-stationary issues with that
empirically what a lot of people
including myself is I wonder it is we
have all this other data so when we're
estimating the gradient right now
typically we're running the policy just
you know four D trajectories and then
we're estimating a gradient with that
and could we maybe use other data to do
that but then it ends up being off
policy because then you're mixing
together data you've gathered four
different policies empirically I think
people often end up using only the data
from the current run and then you're
essentially just estimating V PI I with
this and you're not necessarily mixing
data for many other policies Paraclete
it seems like often it's really helpful
to be on policy and you can reintroduce
is variance so empirically often it's
best I think the jury's still out on it
there's ongoing research on it we've
looked at it Sergei libyans group has
looked at it but most of the time using
the on policy data makes sense yeah it's
another question and main press please I
just wanna confirm so when you say we
fit baseline we're setting baseline
equal to the value that minimizes the
function Europe if we do this if we're
only averaging over the data points that
we have for this current policy when we
do this it's essentially it's
essentially the same as when we were
doing Monte Carlo policy evaluation so
this is almost exactly like Monte Carlo
policy eval where we have a fixed policy
and then we have a parameterised
function to represent it and then we
just want to fit those parameters so we
can best estimate the policy
okay so I'm gonna there's a little bit
of information about auto-da-fé you can
check it in the slides and the things
we're gonna go through next is thinking
about this aspect as I was saying and
then we'll talk some about this so this
part is going to be where we think about
monotonic improvement because once we
have a gradient we have to figure out
how far to go and and can we guarantee
depending on how far we go whether or
not we're going to get a monotonic
improvement and this part is about sort
of giving better estimates of our
gradient ideally with less data and
reducing the variance of it so they're
both important they're doing slightly
different things all right so let's talk
about please
thank you okay
so like we sort of started talking about
before well let's let's talk about first
the baseline so how should we choose the
baseline one thing that we can do for
the baseline is just to like what that
what we're seeing there which is an
empirical estimate of V PI so we could
say in general we want to just have use
V PI I as a baseline that means we have
to compute it somehow and the way we
estimate that could be from Monte Carlo
or it could be from TD methods so what
we've seen so far is using these as a so
so I guess just to be clear here there's
a couple different places we're gonna be
able to maybe switch between doing Monte
Carlo returns and doing something TD
like one is here and another is our
baseline okay so we have a baseline
function here that we're sort of
subtracting off and we also have a GT
prime here and so if we think about our
general equation again so what we have
in this case is we have Delta Theta ya
theta this is our permit this is
specifying our policy parameters and
we've said this is a
I equal to 1 over m sum over I equals 1
to M of some reward well I'll put this
inside sum over T equals 0 to t minus 1
I've changed my mind
okay I'm going to put this out here
because it's going to end up being sort
of a function we can use in lots of
different ways so this is our basic
equation we've been working with we've
said the derivative of the value with
respect to our policy parameters is
approximately as sum over m trajectory's
we've sampled those trajectories from
that policy times the total reward we've
gotten on that trajectory times the sum
over all time steps of the derivative of
the policy with respect to given the
action we took in the state we were in
alright and we said it was very noisy
but I'm biased and now we can think of
changing this as a target so this here
was an unbiased estimator of the value
of the policy and now we can think about
substituting other things in all right
so we can imagine doing all sorts of
things here we could we could do you
know TD or MC methods if we do it with a
value function or if we try to
explicitly compute a value function or
or a state action value function then we
typically call this a critic so a critic
computes B or Q so when we talk about
actor critic methods that's when we have
an explicit parameters representation of
the policy and we have an explicit
generally parameterize representation of
the value or the state action value and
if we have that then we can imagine
using that to change what our target is
I want to emphasize our critic methods
combine these two combined policy plus
critics and probably the most popular
one of this is a three C which is by men
and all this is introduced in 2016 ICML
it's been hugely popular this is a
version for deep neural networks but
actor critic ideas themselves have been
around for a lot longer than that but a
three C is one of the most popular
versions of this 4d parallax
alright so how do we do sort of policy
gradient formulas with value functions
what you could do instead here I shall
put on this site what you could do is
you could have almost the same equation
as we had before
so driven respect to the value function
is equal to an expectation with respect
to the trajectories that you might
encounter the sum over all the time
steps in that trajectory times the
derivative with respect to your policy
parameters times Q of s T W minus B of s
T so instead of having your Monte Carlo
estimates in here you could plug in your
estimate of the Q function and another
way to represent that here is if we
think this is an estimate of value and
this is basically our advantage function
again that it could be R so we had an
advantage function over here you define
an advantage function here but this one
was a function of the Monte Carlo
returns for that episode this is a
different advantage function which is
the Q function which where this could be
maintained by a critic - your baseline
which is an estimate the value function
so they look pretty similar but you can
plug in different choices here and these
are going to have different trade-offs
so the Monte Carlo
estimate of the return is an unbiased
estimate of the value of the current
policy
this is gonna be biased generally but
lower variance all right
so I also want to emphasize here that
when we think about kind of getting this
estimator which we often say the the
critic is going to compute this
estimator it doesn't have to be only
either tee a TD estimate or a Monte
Carlo estimate but you can interpolate
between these is often known as n step
returns so what does that mean so let's
call that let's write this in a slightly
well I'll call this here so let's but
this is a hat okay just to note that you
can think of this is kind of just a
function it's gonna be an estimate of
your state action value function and so
what we could have is we could have an
estimator of estimator of the value from
time step T onwards which is equal to
the actual this is the actual one we got
on time step I so I'm gonna call this
I'm gonna call this sort of I come a 1
and this is gonna be then the actual
reward you got on time step T in episode
I plus gamma V of s T plus 1 so this
should look almost exactly like td0
style estimates we talked about this
before so this says I got I look at the
actual immediate 1 step forward I got
and then I bootstrap I add in the value
so this would be I'd get this value
function for my critic and I would plug
that in and then that would be my target
but then I would use in this equation ok
so that would be one thing you do you
can do so we've seen this and we've seen
a lot of this which I'm gonna call the
infinite or Monte Carlo version and this
one is you sum over all T prime all the
way to the end of the episode of gamma
to the T prime minus T
times are prime so this is the Monte
Carlo return where we just sum up we
don't do any bootstrapping and we sum up
all the roads and the episodes but as
you can see here there should be you
know there's probably some way to
interpolate between these two and these
are often known as n step returns and so
for example you could do this you could
say I'm gonna add in the reward at time
step I and the reward I got a time step
2 T plus 1 and then I'm gonna bootstrap
so this was just sort of one of the
estimators that are in between these two
extremes one is you only take in one
step of reward another one is to you sum
up all the rewards and then there's a
whole bunch of interpolation you could
do between those why would you want to
do that well this one is generally going
to be somewhat biased the low variance
this is going to be unbiased but really
high variance there's no reason to
assume that the best solution is on
either of those two extremes and so you
could interpolate between a TV estimate
and a Monte Carlo estimate and all of
these just form returns that then you
could subtract off the baseline for two
and all this would probably be
considered a hyper parameter that we
could choose through validation a cross
validation is that what people do here
is that's kind of too computationally
intensive so you just have to pick
something machine learning this would be
just considered as some sort of hyper
parameter you know you could turn this
into N and you would decide like how
many steps do you do um do people do and
the question was do you do people do
that and reinforcement learning is that
considered too expensive you certainly
could I I think it's an interesting
question I feel like the tricks that
people do in this case I think I
probably see more of this but it varies
more using the tv0 doing a lot of
bootstrapping
but it probably depends on your
application domain another thing that it
would likely to pend on is if your
domains really mark off or not so this
case this is still working this is
giving you a real estimate of the return
of your policy even if you're doing is
at mark off this case you're making a
much stronger Markovian assumption so
you also might wanted to make do
different things depending on your
domain and also how expensive it is to
collect data alright so this gives us
sort of a different way to plug things
in to that vanilla policy gradient
algorithm I put over there so you could
plug in these sort of targets instead
over there to trade off between bias and
variance when you're doing this estimate
of the gradient so what this is doing
here is it's changing what our targets
are and it's changing how we're
computing our gradient but then the next
thing I want to talk about is this part
which is once we've actually got our
gradient however we've chosen to get it
we have to actually figure out how far
to go along that gradient so why might
this be important well it might be
important because this is just a local
approximation you're giving a local
estimate of the gradient yeah it's a
great question again depends so you can
either you can do this often
asynchronously so you can have different
threads and different networks for your
critic and for your policy and principle
you could just be updating your critic
all the time like you know you could be
using dqn for this and doing lots and
lots of backups I in general it depends
I think you need to have a schedule yeah
so often you might do something like 10
100 it really varies by application um
but there's no reason that the critic
needs to be updated only on the same
schedule at which you're updating the
policy and doing a asynchronously often
makes a lot of sense all right so if we
think about what's happening here here's
our parametrized policy here's our value
we have some crazy function hey and then
we are computing our gradient and this
gradient locally is pretty good
so kind of round here things look linear
and things look pretty good but of
course as we get further out like here
it's gonna be bad like if we if we try
to follow the gradient too far we're
gonna get an estimate that's very
different than the real value function
so when we're taking step sizes in this
case it ends up being important to
consider this fact of sort of how far
out do you want your step sizes to be
let me just get this back to okay so we
want to figure out how far we should go
in the gradient and that's important now
you might say okay this is always true
right like you always need to be careful
when you're doing gradient descent or
essent in any supervised learning
problem whenever using stochastic
gradient descent of course you don't
want to go too far along your step size
because you could overshoot and you're
using this linear approximation that's
bad why does anybody doesn't me have any
sense about why this might be even worse
in the reinforcement learning case I
might be even more important to think
about the step size it has to do with
where the data comes from yeah that's
the DVD cups and you might have your
data's being generated by an iid
distribution it doesn't matter what
choices you just made for your
stochastic gradient sent in RL that is
determining the next policy we're using
inside of our iteration to gather data
so we're not gonna you know if we take a
really bad if we get really really bad
policies we just may be getting no data
towards the actual optimum of this
function so it's even more important to
sort of carefully think about where
we're going along here and ideally
hopefully get monotonic improvement so
this is this is the really it's very
important in the reinforcement learning
case to think about how we're doing this
step size because this determines the
data we collect
pi and therefore data in one version of
one of my colleagues talks about a
similar problem he sort of has the
picture of the roadrunner running off
the cliff right and like then you if
you're in a part where your policy is
just really really bad you make it no
more useful data then you can't get a
good estimate there of the gradient and
then you're just stuck you might get in
a really really bad Optima okay so we'd
like to think carefully about this part
so one thing that we could do is do
something like line search so we're
talking about right now sort of how do
we do
so how to do step sizes so one thing we
could do is try to do some sort of line
search along the gradient and this is
okay but it's a little bit expensive so
it's simple but it's expensive and it
tends to sort of ignore where the linear
approximation is good so we'd like to do
better than this so now we're going to
go back to that point that I mentioned
at the start which is what we'd really
like to be able to do is when we're
doing this updating we would like to
ensure monotonic improvement and so can
we kind of choose our step sizes in a
way or choose how far along the gradient
to go in order to achieve monotonic
improvement so what our goal is going to
be is we'd like to have it so that the
PI of I plus one is greater than or
equal to B PI and we're hoping to
achieve this by changing how big of a
step size you take all right so let's
think about what our objective function
is again so we're getting we have our
value our parameters value so B of theta
it's equal to the expected value under
our policy that's defined by theta just
the sum over T equals 0 to infinity of
gamma t r st a t under our policy okay
and that's where we just look at the the
series of states we get under our policy
that's our basic equation here in terms
of expressing the value of a
parameterised policy and what we would
like to do here is we would like to get
a new policy that has a better value but
the problem is that we have samples from
an old policy so when we're doing this
we're gathering policies with pi and
then we're trying to figure out what our
pi plus 1 should be so this is going to
fundamentally involve so we have access
to we have access to trajectories that
are sampled from PI of theta and we now
want us to predict the value of B a PI
of theta
I'll put PI I I plus 1 so we'd like to
sort of now figure out what a new value
would be if we update these prayer
update these parameters in some way and
take like a max you know we'd like to
figure out what the new parameters are
but this is fundamentally an off policy
problem because we have data from our
last policy and we want to figure out
what our next policy should be ok so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna first
re-express the value of our policy in
terms of the advantage the value of our
new policy in terms of the advantage
over our old policy so I'm gonna move
down the middle policy gradient for now
okay so what we have is we have V of
theta tilde so that could be like our
new parametrize policy it's gonna be
equal to the value of our old
parametrized policy so whatever we had
before plus the following the
distribution over the states and actions
we get if we were to run our new policy
no we don't know that but let's I'm at
let's ignore that for a second
of sum over T equals zero to infinity
gamma to the T the advantage PI so this
is just generally holds this doesn't
have to do anything necessarily with
being parametrized this is just saying
the value of any policy which is here
parameterize by PI tilde is equal to the
value of another policy plus the sum
over the states and actions you'd reach
under your target policy of the
advantage you get of taking this new
policy over the old policy so that's
that just expresses how we can say what
about how and the value of a new policy
relates to the value of the old policy
it's exactly the same as the old values
policy plus the advantage you'd get if
you were to run the new policy and look
at the state action distribution you'd
encounter yes yeah so you're doing it
let me write this questions Goodwin let
me just write this out to be horrible
okay so we've got V of theta plus sum
over all the states and we're gonna use
mu P tilde of s so remember this was the
stationary distribution we use this to
denote the station in distribution over
states that we'd reach if we were to run
our new policy which is parameterize
time's the advantage function okay so
what this is saying here is this st and
80 are under our desired policy and the
advantage here is using the old one so
this is long as to compare so what does
this do allowing us to compare si s T 80
minus Q of s T our old policy and this
is under so it's allowing us to compare
how much better is it if we take like
our new action all right but one of the
problems of this is we don't know this
yeah
oh thank you oh no make allowing me to
clarify that so in this case what we're
doing is we're taking an expectation
over all time steps and this is saying
over the trajectories that we'd get to
under our new policy I've now
reformulated and said well we have a
stationary distribution over States if
we look at what is the probability of
reaching those states and then we weigh
that by the advantage so we went from a
time averaging to a state averaging that
makes sense so we can either think of
our value function averaging our value
function across time steps or we can
think here is averaging across all the
states and what is for each state what
is the relative value you get by
following your new policy versus your
old policy oh sorry thank you then that
there was our typos all right so this
would be under so we look at the the
states that for each state what is the
probability we'd reach that state under
our new policy what is the relative
advantage
the thing that you pointed to until
never here this is our original one plus
six officers between high data sodium
and Toby I I was just doing this year to
make it clear pipes a final de is also
high tilde is parametrized by this is a
policy privatized by theta tilde like
you okay episode eight so we couldn't on
that side either any I wanted to just be
clear
often this notation goes back and forth
between you things you want to make the
policy explicit let's was just the
parameters I think it's more clear to
have a policy and parameters here but
off of me also use the you can just
directly parametrize the value function
in terms of data it's supposed to be PI
tilde of theta but I'm gonna just use
eat any of these is fine
is anybody confused about what this is I
mean if it's easier I can just go like
this
I can just remove all of those okay so
this is just what I ever say PI tilde
that's the policy that's parametrized by
the new that's your new policy okay and
that's this I know this longer
so we have any questions about
sanitation lastly so I get somewhat a
little bit of computes no sleep just
because it's a little bit different from
the slides and I'm just wondering
wondering so in this case do we sum over
a possible actions for a given state or
as a people noted here do we assume that
we take a single action per by using the
policy which is what we have okay let's
say B theta tilde I'll go with the exact
same notation as the slides it's equal
to V of theta plus sum over States our
stationary distribution over PI tilde of
s so this is the distribution we get
this is the discounted weighted
distribution under our target policy and
there hi tilde sum over a so this is the
weighted fair this is the weighted
distribution under the states we went
from the time domain to thinking about
the distribution over states times
looking at all the actions we might take
under our target policy and the relative
advantage of each of those over our
previous policy and this should look
very very similar to invitation learning
in certain ways right like so we're
again sort of thinking about instead of
thinking about subbing rewards over time
steps we're thinking about what is the
stationary distribution we might get to
under a new policy and how that compares
to the stationary distribution we would
have had under our old policy and what
we're looking at so far
we're looking at the stationary
distribution under our target policy the
problem is we don't know this so we
can't calculate this this is just an
expression but this is unknown because
we don't have any samples from PI tilde
we only have samples from PI so we can't
compute this why would we add just to go
back why are we trying to do any of this
we're trying to do this because when we
do vanilla policy gradient we're gonna
be trying to figure out a new policy
that has a value that's better than our
old policy what we did here is we tried
to estimate the derivative of the
current pala of the current policy but
we don't know anything yet about the
value once we take that step and so what
we're trying to do here is to say well
can we somehow understand what the value
will be of a new policy before we
execute it and we're gonna do that by
trying to relate it to what is our value
of the previous policy plus some sort of
distance between the old policy and the
new policy
ideally computed in terms of things we
can actually evaluate using our current
samples that's where we're trying to go
to
all right so we have this nice
expression but we can't compute it so
we're gonna make up a new objective
function we're gonna do this one sort of
backwards because we're going to make it
up and then we're gonna show why it's a
good thing to do so what are we trying
to do we'd like to use something like
this if we had this then we could
compare the value of the new policy to
the value of the old policy the problem
is we don't have this because we don't
have that and the stationary
distribution under the new policy so
what we're gonna do instead is we're
gonna define an objective function L pi
which is as follows it's the value of
your old policy plus a sum over all your
state's the stationary distribution
discounted distribution of your old
policy this is where it's different so
this is the old your current policy okay
and then the rest of the expression
looks the same now notice we can compute
this okay this is we could just average
over all the trajectories we have for
the current episode we could estimate
our stationary distribution from our
current data we could know for a new
policy what its action so if someone
gives me a new policy PI I could
evaluate this and I could also evaluate
the advantage okay because this
advantage is defined only in terms of my
previous PI so as long as if I have a
representation of the state action value
function for my old policy I could
evaluate this so now all of this is a
value available this might not be a good
thing to do but we can compute this you
can there's just some new parameters for
computing so our policy is always
parameterised by some set of parameters
you could either think of that it's just
being a new policy or you can think of
that as the new parameters either is
fine
you're pretty good explain why if you're
given on the eye tell me why you won't
be able to calculate Krishna's if you're
given pie to the new policy why can you
not compute new it's a good question
because don't have any data from that
there's almost giving you a new policy
there can be ways to approximate this
but the only data that you have right
now is from the current old policy from
PI so you've run this out M times you've
got M trajectories which are M
trajectories gathered under your old
policy pi okay you don't have any data
from tai tilde and in general if i tilde
is not the same as pi you're gonna get
different trajectories so you don't have
any direct estimate of this that makes
sense to everybody so if we go back to
the vanilla policy gradient what did we
do we had a policy pi I we ran it out
and we got D trajectories from that PI I
we could use that to estimate that new
that just gives us on policy data of
what are the states and actions we
experience when we're following PI I we
don't have any data of PI plus one yet
we haven't run it an estimate of the
stationary distribution for the old
policy you basically look at all the
data that you have like all the
trajectories and see basically what
fraction of the time you're spending it
one state you go from just raw data
these 2d trajectories to MU you could
just count you know I mean in general if
you're in really high dimensions you
want to do something smoother than that
you want to approximate the density
function but essentially you can just
directly you know type of so you could
just count them just like how many times
do I get to this stage and take this
action and then that would give you a
direct estimate of the Meuse in general
you gonna want some sort of parametric
function in high dimensions but you
couldn't fit that using you could
imagine this is privatised itself and
you can fit that using your existing on
policy data intuitively does this work
because we assumed the distribution of
the states can't change too much spoken
policies I
question is enjoyed of Li why this work
I have not told you why this works I've
just said this is something we could do
and that it's computable and I haven't
told you yet why this is a good thing to
do but we're gonna show that that this
is gonna allow us to get to something
which is a lower bound and then we can
improve on those lower bounds okay so
just a quick thing to notice here which
is if you do this if you do L PI of Pi
so that's just what is this objective
function if you plug in the old policy
there this is just equal to V beta so if
you evaluate this function under the
same policy it just gives you the value
all right
so conservative I'll just briefly we'll
have to continue this further later but
so we can use this to do what's known as
conservative policy iteration a
conservative policy iteration and the
intuition here is let's just first to
start with mixed a mixed policy so
imagine that you have a new policy which
is a mix of it of an old policy and
something different so you have 1 minus
alpha at times your old policy plus
alpha times some new policy PI prime ok
so that just means you take some old
your current existing policy and you mix
in something else ok then in this case
you can guarantee that the value of your
new policy is greater than or equal to
if you to take this objective function
here and you evaluate it with your new
policy so you take your new policy you
evaluate out to your old policy you plug
that in that's computable because you
have data from your old policy minus 2
epsilon gamma 1 minus gamma squared
alpha squared so you could lower bound
the value of your new policy in terms of
whatever this objective function is when
you compute it
- this expression I just want to close
with two other thoughts which is note
again that if you plug in alpha is equal
to 0 that means that PI nu is the same
as piled and this goes to 0 which means
that and since we know that this is
equal to that that just says that your
new policy has to be greater than or
equal to your old policy and since the
same their policies are all the same
this is tight okay so we this is a
little bit different than we expected
because of the technical challenges with
PDF so what I'll just close with here is
that the next steps will go from this is
to show we can use this to essentially
drive a lower bound on the new value
function and we can show basically that
if we improve across the lower bounds
that were guaranteed that the actual
value function is monotonically
improving so we will go through that I
haven't decided yet whether we'll go
through that on Monday because that's
the midterm review or if we will wait on
that until the following week after the
midterm the policy gradient homework
won't be released until after the
midterm so we have a bit more time for
that and I'll go through also like the
main takeaways with policy gradient
stuff when we conclude this part Thanks